demain nous célèbrerons le 26e
anniversaire de la mort de claude
françois
et pourtant le chanteur n'a jamais été
aussi présent dans les mémoires grâce en
particulier au film podium avec benoît
poelvoorde toujours dans les salles on y
découvre le moulin de dannemois ou
cloclo habitait c'est dans ce petit
village de l'essonne qui a été inhumé la
star c'est un véritable lieu de balade
et même de pèlerinage pour ses nombreux
fans et n'diaye christine donato et
potron minet et est ici est joli podium
un film à succès plus de 2 millions
d'entrées les commerçants de danois ne
pouvait rêver d'une meilleure publicité
au moulin l'ancienne résidence de claude
françois transformés en restaurants ont
fait visiter les lieux aux nouveaux fans
souvent jeunes ravis de reconnaître les
décors du film on peut même dire que
quelque part c'est le signe qu'il aura
fait connaître claude françois et l'ailé
les enfants sont très intéressés ils
veulent absolument voir le moulin ce
fameux boulet où a été tourné le film en
partie et nous sommes très heureux de
les recevoir parce qu'en fait pour nous
c'est la relève lé savoir comment il a
vécu dans le moulin en fait à mme soucy
bol puis je voulais voir de plus près
son voyage lire at ellis et pas parce
pas évident au cimetière où repose
l'idole toujours la même qu y
le film donne l'occasion aux
inconditionnels de transmettre la
passion à leurs enfants
il a tenu absolument à voir la tombe
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est là
aujourd'hui on était vert mercredi soir
le film et c'était vraiment faim moi
j'ai trouvé un très très bon fion mais
avec ou sans film la passion cloclo
remplit toujours le tiroir caisse de
l'épicerie surtout à la veille du 26e
anniversaire de sa disparition par jour
dans le village on doit avoir de 3000
personnes qui viennent donc
automatiquement ou vont aussi bien
d'état bac de l'épicerie que des
souvenirs plus le restant c'est certain
que pendant quelques jours c'est une
manne qui vient pas du désert mais il
marchait mais cette effervescence
touristique et commercial bouscule la
tranquillité de certains habitants tu
préfère se tenir à l'écart
j'ai vu qu'il